I recently came across a fact that
really surprised me a lot
the country of Panama observed around
119 deaths per 100 000 people during the
period of 2000 to 2004 due to
cardiovascular diseases like heart
attacks and heart failures whereas on
the same time span at an island close to
Panama in a tribe known as gunayala just
eight people died for every 100 000
people due to the same diseases
this basically means that a death rate
of Panama is 14.8 times higher than the
island in the same time frame
the reason for this magic well the
people of this island have been
consuming cocoa on a regular basis since
centuries
hi guys and welcome to mansimplified
today's video is going to be about how
dark chocolate improves our mood our
stress levels and its beneficial
antioxidant properties
in today's fast-paced world stress is a
very common factor that cuts down on our
life expectancies
stress depression and a lack of
motivation are major factors why many
turn to psychoactive agents and drugs to
feel better this is why today's world
calls for something healthy that helps
to boost our energy and release our
stress be it in the form of green
veggies exercise or something Even
Better Dark Chocolate well dark
chocolate is an amazing understated
product historically it was considered
the food of gods by ancient
mesoamericans to them dark chocolate was
gifted to humans to heal the physical
emotional and spiritual pain but what
does science say about it well that's
why we are here
chocolate is bad period but dark
chocolate with at least 85 percent cocoa
or more has proven to have some amazing
health benefits usually chocolates that
are sold on shells are Dutch Chocolate
dutched here means that the cocoa
content in the dark chocolate is quite
literally stripped off additional sugars
are added and it also contains a lot of
saturated fats and calories whereas dark
chocolate is bitter now if you find it
difficult to understand which one is
which generally chocolates that are
bitter in taste are good for your health
the more the bitter the more the better
researchers recommend having dark
chocolates with at least 85 percent
cocoa or more
dark chocolate contains a lot of
essential minerals amino acids like
tryptophan and some naturally occurring
substances like polyphenols caffeine and
theobromine that have some very unique
health benefits
now let's get straight into the topic
and let's talk about the three important
ways by which dark chocolate improves
our mood and relieves our stress as a
bonus towards the end of the video we'll
suggest you a few tips on how you could
include dark chocolate in your diet so
make sure to watch the video till the
end
number one dark chocolate contains
essential minerals that help to boost
our mood
cocoa beans the main ingredient in dark
chocolate happen to be one of the top
seven foods on the planet that are rich
in magnesium and magnesium if you didn't
know happens to be an essential mineral
when it comes to calmness it's a
naturally occurring relaxant that helps
to deactivate adrenaline
a study conducted by Dr bhenood Abbasi
and his team discovered that magnesium
supplements relax human bodies to such
an extent that their supplementation has
proven to be effective in patients with
insomnia not that a dark chocolate drink
will knock you to sleep but it does go a
long way in helping your body relax and
easing your mind
it is quite important to note that
magnesium deficiency is quite common and
a decrease in magnesium levels could
lead to insomnia muscle twitching
anxiety and palpitations which are all
signs of stress
the Magnesium present in dark chocolate
is a great way to keep anxiety out of
sight and reduce irritability
magnesium is just one such compound
found in dark chocolate that helps with
lightening our mood there are many other
minerals found in dark chocolate that
help with our mood such as iron zinc and
copper
number two dark chocolate contains
essential amino acids that help to lower
stress
dark chocolate contains a very important
amino acid known as tryptophan
tryptophan is a precursor to two
naturally occurring wonderful compounds
in our body serotonin and melatonin
serotonin nicknamed as feel good
neurotransmitter is a mood stabilizer
that controls well-being and happiness
and fun fact if you didn't know what
anti-hypertensive medications do well
this simply increases serotonin levels
available to our brain cells not only
does dark chocolate help to increase the
serotonin levels in the body but it also
boosts the production of melatonin
melatonin is a naturally occurring
hormone present in our body and it is
secreted by the pineal gland in the
brain in response to Darkness it helps
to control the Circadian rhythm of the
body and it basically acts as a chemical
messenger that signals our brain to
decrease the activity levels and get
ready to sleep
this is the reason why you feel calmer
and less anxious after consuming dark
chocolate
it is important to note that tryptophan
is heat volatile and therefore
non-existent in cooked chocolate making
raw chocolates the best way to obtain
dietary tryptophan the combined effects
of Serotonin and melatonin acting on our
body are one of the major reasons why
dark chocolate helps to reduce our
stress and in long-term use cases even
prevent stress also
Point number three dark chocolate
contains important antioxidants that
help us to relax
dark chocolates are one of the richest
sources of flavonoids a type of
polyphenol found in cocoa flavonoids are
antioxidants that have been shown to
reduce oxidative stress in US
but how does this translate to reduced
stress levels in a recent study done in
Brazil by Dr Clarissa M her team found
out that levels of stress directly
relate to the oxidative activity in the
brain by reducing the levels of
oxidative stress in the brain the stress
levels of these test subjects were also
reduced and dark chocolates are rich in
flavonoids which enable the brain to
handle oxidative stress in a much
efficient manner but things don't end
here flavonoids have other roles too
flavonoids have proven effect of
increasing the levels of nitric oxide in
the blood vessels nitric oxide is a
natural vasodilator which causes our
blood vessels to relax and this
increases the blood flow especially
towards the brain and the muscles which
causes overall relaxation of the body
and the mind
if that wasn't convincing enough the
flavonoids found in dark chocolate are
extremely potent anti-inflammatory
agents with known mechanisms beneficial
for brain and cardiovascular health it
has also been proven to increase the
cognitive function of our brain
also consuming dark chocolate on a
regular basis decreases the circulating
levels of cortisol and epinephrine both
of which are associated with stress
the three points that we discuss here
are most prominent mechanisms by which
dark chocolate boosts our mood and helps
to reduce stress levels new studies are
always on the lookout for other methods
on how dark chocolate effectively helps
our mental well-being dark chocolate
benefits many other organ systems and
more than just our molds it also helps
with productivity and other functions as
well in this video we have just focused
on how it benefits our mental health if
you'd like to know more about how dark
chocolate effects are other systems let
us know in the comments below
hike shakes or prefer having dark
chocolate in the form of a drink let me
show you how you can create a relishing
drink
you can make a dark chocolate shake
using 85 percent cocoa powder without
adding additional flavors or sugar add
skimmed milk of your choice and a
teaspoon of peanut butter if you like
cinnamon powder vanilla extract or even
a bit of Honey add them in blend it well
and top it off with some nuts this
should fill your cup with calmness and
help you feel at ease
having this unsweetened drink daily
could boost your productivity throughout
the day and if you are prone to anxiety
and stress episodes this drink will
definitely make a difference in your
routine if the drink proves too much of
a task for you or if you're a person on
the go all the time a simple dark
chocolate bar would do the trick for you
we would love to know how dark chocolate
has made change in your life I've
intuited links to some good dark
chocolates in the description below so
make sure to check them out
don't let the bitterness of dark
chocolate keep you away from its
benefits so the next time you're looking
for a natural way to improve your mood
remember to reach out for some dark
chocolate
that's all from this video if you like
to view more informative videos like
these consider subscribing to our
Channel if you found this video helpful
and would like to promote such
interesting topics you can support us on
our patreon page all links are in the
description below
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you in the next video bye and take care